foreign
is in Scranton Pennsylvania hi Dan
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Dave and crew thank you for taking
my call sure
so here's my situation I'm 61 years old
I'm going to be 62 in January I'll be
retiring from Corporate America I'm
married 42 years I purchased a home in
Pennsylvania this past April while my
New York home is up for sale and for
that Pennsylvania home I got a 30-year
variable rate mortgage for 495 000 and
it's currently fixed at 2.8 percent for
the next 10 years with a payment of 2700
a month I sold my New York home shortly
after I closed on the PA home so my
question is should I take the 500 000
from the sale of my New York home and
pay off the Pennsylvania mortgage or
should I invest that 500 000 in a
managed Fidelity Vanguard or some other
index funds and use that interest on the
500k to pay off the PA home at least for
the next 10 years and then reassess the
situation because I have no debt other
than that PA mortgage my wife and I
should be bringing home about 11 000 a
month when we retire as I have a pension
and I got 1.1 million in my 401k which
is mostly sending in cash money market
now why what should I do why is it in
cash and money markets
um
well you know I've had it invested in
index funds for two 25 years and I've
done well and they're on sale right now
I'm nervous I mean had I had that in
there where the Market's losing 20 this
year so that's what scared me uh I I
dabbled back in about a month ago I put
the 300 000 into the market again split
it in Index Fund small medium large uh
cap index funds 33 and a third so
I I don't know I don't think the market
hey I'm your age and I think the
Market's on sale I haven't taken any out
and I'm putting money in I think it's a
good buy right now
so you can do what you want to do but I
wouldn't have a million ones sitting on
the sidelines making no money that drive
me nuts
um now what about the mortgage I pay it
off tomorrow
and not use the interest on that you've
asked this question suggesting I have
the answer six times
um and so you really don't want to pay
off the mortgage you really want to
invest it but let me tell you why I'm
telling you to pay it off okay in our
study of ten thousand millionaires that
are sitting about where you're sitting
the vast majority of them were between
one and three million dollar net worth
which is exactly where you're sitting uh
we found we did not find any of them
that said not one not a single one that
said the way I became a millionaire was
borrowing on my home to invest in the
stock market
none of them said that
and effectively that is your question
isn't it
yeah should I borrow all my home at 2.8
percent and invest in index funds oh
wait I've got a million one on the
sidelines because I'm scared of the
market and I don't think it's going to
do that well you're talking out of both
sides of your mouth
you answered my question
no you're hey Dan listen here's the
thing uh if I were in your shoes and I
and I am in the sense that we're about
the same age I would be a hundred
percent debt free and I'd get back in
the market uh with the other money and
you're gonna have a great life the sense
of peace
that you have when you have zero debt
is not definable with mathematics
and you've worked your butt off and you
have done a great job of building a high
quality retirement dude you're a stud
you have killed this
and I'm sure I've used your principles
I've been putting 13 of my salary away
for 28 years and you're and you're a
baby steps millionaire an everyday
millionaire you you know you you nobody
gave you any money you're the guy that
got up left the cave killed something
and drag it home you showed up at work
when you didn't feel like it and got
stuff done you got grit you're that guy
that's how you got where you are I know
that about you because I can tell I can
see it in the numbers
you don't get where you are being a
melting snowflake okay you get where you
are grinding and and showing up and
being a man of honor and a man of Duty
and that that's who you are am I wrong
that's what I did yeah and so and and it
wasn't it wasn't fancy and it wasn't
sexy and all your get rich quick friends
thought you were slow
but you weren't slow you kicked all of
them's butt because here you sit with it
probably about a two million dollar net
worth give or take and and you did it
man so I I want you to enjoy this season
where you've lived like no one else
you've paid a price now you get to live
and give like no one else and not having
a mortgage while you're on vacation
somewhere around the world with your
wife enjoying your 42 years of marriage
um it's it's a different thing man and I
want that for you I want that sense of
peace that sense of power uh we don't
need to Arbitrage your home we don't
need to leverage your home for you to
win you won
you already won yeah and I love the
advice that you give because I just walk
through that scenario and he's got a
house that's right at uh he didn't tell
us he told us what the mortgage is it's
probably worth more than the 495 way
more than that and so now all of a
sudden with having no debt you have this
asset that's extremely valuable if you
need to liquidate it's there not to
mention he's invested you know and he's
done so much it is no he's not going to
need it but that's the whole idea it's
not carry the debt at all this idea of
well I'm going to pay my mortgage off
with the interest what's the temptation
to follow that you're gonna have twenty
thousand he's got 11 000 already coming
in when he puts that million one to work
and creates another 10 15 000 bucks a
month yeah he's gonna have twenty twenty
five thousand dollars a month to live on
and have no payments
this sounds like a good life to me
I like your life it sounds like the
American dream and I'm proud of you I'm
proud of you man he's I he's who we're
trying to get people to be 100 he's the
poster child yeah yeah
well neither one of your children
anymore but yeah
she's a post or something it's a
metaphor or a poster something's Ken but
we're not sure which you guys are young
still I think you got to get to 80 85
before you can call yourself old in
today's world uh just the older I get
the older my grandpa when he was 80 he
kept talking about this guy down the
street he said that old man and I'm like
Grandpa you're 80. he goes yeah but he's
older than me he's a old man so that's
true no matter how old you get somebody
older hopefully
well at some point you run out of
candidates though
uh listen that guy's Dan Dan you're a
stud man yeah I'm so proud of you and I
would just enjoy this and uh don't
overthink it you didn't get here by
overthinking it you got here by
executing
steady
[Music]
rhythm
you stuck with it the grit that's how
you got here just keep doing that
not by trying to get fancy